today's topic women are about to lie to
you for the next 25 minutes
[Music]
i wish i didn't get plastic surgery
three
two
one go
um i had a rhinoplasty and a breast
augmentation it has helped me overcome a
lot of self-image
issues that i've had and i do not regret
my either of those at all however
sometimes i do
wish that i was more natural just
because i feel like society puts a big
emphasis on
you know being naturally beautiful
for me how society puts a big emphasis
on
being natural
and doing all those practices
ghostbastic surgery to look natural
it's like watching one of those teen
magazines
be confident about yourself yeah
yeah just be strong be a strong woman
flip the page lose 20 pounds in 30 days
flip the page
cream cream cream the latest secret to
get rid of that
you know there's two there's two reasons
i think why society puts that emphasis
on natural
one there's something very like
off-putting whenever i look at somebody
who's got a clear nose job or their lips
done or their titties for some reason
for me it flips a switch in my brain and
i'm like oh that's plastic one and two i
think there's also something to be said
about buying your way there it's like as
a dude you can get in shape you work
through they get that process and
there's a certain level of respect that
people court you because you went and
put in that time
whereas if you just buy your way there
then there's a little bit of like meh i
don't i don't really [ __ ] with it i was
insecure about my breasts before i
didn't like the size i was like you know
maybe if they were a little bigger like
so and i went ahead i i did it
and i
i could never go back
like it makes me so happy like i look at
myself in the mirror and i'm like damn
girl
where do you come from my like okay from
the surgeon's office that's where you
come from what do you think that says
about us our society where you can
pay to get some surgery done like just
elective like maybe they cut off your
piece of your eyebrow and then you feel
better what does that say about us that
we put so much pressure on people to
look good that they only feel content
included with their lives when they do
that and also
what are we saying about society we're
saying yeah do that to be happy it's
fine because like it feels like we're
not treating the underlying issue which
is the pressure that we put on people
yeah to look like this right and then
we're saying no it's perfectly
acceptable to cut up your face or cut up
your titties or cut up and also there's
a health risk associated with a lot of
these surgeries whether it's babies or
the implants so to me it's wild that two
things exist at the same time body
positivity
and plastic surgery
i for the life of me cannot understand
how both of these things coexist coexist
yeah yeah they try to tell you love your
body
however it comes was like you trying to
change it cut yourself up you not yeah
but anyways go ahead there is a lot of
pressure that is about beauty standards
and stuff like that there's a lot of
standard about
aging and that's something that we have
to tackle it's like at some point when
the ladies when the ladies get to a
certain age it's like if they're almost
disposable so they want to counter that
if the who wants to be disposable yeah
you know i mean so i can understand the
price that's around that that's [ __ ]
up to feel like you're disposable but no
we're not dealing with that but it's
easier to deal with the other side where
you look good than just not dealing with
the fact that people have a due date on
them someone which is [ __ ] up but it
is what it is i my whole entire life
felt uncomfortable with my boobs because
they were in a regular shape and that
was never going to change unless i got a
surgery i could never
regret it because i feel so much more
confident even though they're not even
like fully dropped and shaped yet hi i
love my plastic surgery i've had over
procedures i had a lot of bad
experiences but yes yes
yes you did
220 yes
[Music]
exactly that
yes ma um
we believe you oh yeah yeah yeah listen
all i keep thinking about is chocolate
fondue
that is the only chocolate phone dumb
hey man maybe this is the wrong thing to
say
isn't it time to slow down the surgeries
when you start looking like the saw mask
you know that clown yeah i'm not gonna
go and
clown my [ __ ] on they look about
like plastic because it's a different
deeper issue i don't know what that
person's going through you know when we
say there's levels to this [ __ ] there is
level for this [ __ ] i believe that there
is levels you get a little injection
here a little injection there blah blah
i understand i get it
it's like whatever people train it's
like there's people out there that take
steroids to be a swole ass bartender
it's like
there's no use to that i could at least
understand that there's a lot of
pressure to be competitive and you're in
the sports uh industry and you have to
compete and then you think about taking
uh steroids i don't agree with it but i
understand the process how this is
linked to the money that you're going to
be making and it's your living and stuff
like that and or you take storage to
recuperate i get that but you gonna take
steroids to be a swole ass
bartender
you're gonna you're gonna injure
yourself injure your body have a whole
lot of risk your nuts might not be uh
working you're gonna be aggressive you
might have roy just to be a swole ass
bartender now if i transpose myself to
that that's a bit of the same thing it's
that you're doing all that and there's a
lot of risk for what
but it is what it is i would let my
children get plastic surgery three
two
one go
if my child was
underage i
wouldn't sign off on it because i would
like them to mature more and elective
surgery i think is
a big emotional role roller coaster the
whole healing process and
getting the operation and
by the time they're 18 that is up to
them and i would support them because
obviously i'd be a hypocrite otherwise
what's underage
for plastic surgery because 18 for
plastic surgery i believe is very
underage
very
this is not a legal thing it's how your
body works okay i believe that 25 is
underage for plastic surgery your body's
not fully what it is all you know once
you hit them 30s
you you know pretty much how your body
is going to look like 25 not so much
there's going to be some other shifts so
18 is super underage
25 to me is still underage because of
outer body function you want to get a
boob job at 25 and be like why because
my breasts not being in it
oh i'd advise you to wait but hey to
each day own i guess it's none of my
business i am from venezuela and
venezuela is very big on plastic surgery
in my country also it's very common to
gift
like quinceaneras
like do you want your nose done a
rhinoplasty if you don't like your nose
you're 16 17 you can be under 18 and you
get that as a as a birthday present just
because something's common doesn't mean
it's good okay
there's a lot of things culture that
happened back in my country that are
normal that aren't necessarily always
good same thing over here
the reason why in latin american
countries specifically venezuela they do
that is because there's such an emphasis
on beauty and being attractive that
they're starting them off young because
you understand how it progresses you in
life but it doesn't mean it's a good and
a healthy thing
it's not
to tell everybody the way that you're
born it's like man
okay
and this i think
really kind of changed my mind because
you know we always talk about the
individual the individual and then they
brought up the topic of kids and then it
all came full circle for me what
happened it's like
your kid comes to you and says i don't
feel comfortable with myself you're
perfect as you are and he looks at your
face and you're all cut up
how do you expect this person to have
any sense of self-esteem
when your comfort with yourself was
there lacking so much that you needed to
go underneath a knife to feel
comfortable and feel good about yourself
yeah you get what i'm saying yeah let's
not pretend also okay there's a lot of
disingenuous people who come and say
well how do you know that they weren't
comfortable with themselves listen a lot
of us have insecurities a lot of us my
forehead jawline i could probably pick a
bunch of things okay all right some
folks gonna say this and if they could
some of them would change it and some of
them
we just live with it okay
i just don't know how you could look at
young people and say you should be okay
with yourself when you were never okay
with yourself kids are perceptive they
know you're full of [ __ ]
so think about the message you sent to
the next generation
like guys
you know we love to do this whole
individual if it's you it's fine and i'm
i'm generally for that but then we also
have to think about what do our
individual choices mean in a societal
context because the individual doesn't
come above that oftentimes we act like
that what do they want to do with their
life is fine i'm not saying we should
make things illegal what i'm trying to
say is it has an implication on the rest
of the community the same way when you
got these celebrities and they're
getting all these nose jobs and they're
making a comment and then all of a
sudden people want to look like them how
many people are kylie jenner look likes
how many people are what's that little
tall white girl small white girl who
looks like she's 17 forever ariana
grande oh yeah how many people get
surgery to look like her yeah you think
what i'm saying yeah our individual
choices has an impact has an impact on
others definitely it sends out a message
you get a surgery on yourself it sends a
message yeah undoubtedly so so i just
first i guess this is a discomfort that
i'm starting to feel now because i'm
like yo no wonder we're talking about
kids getting surgery now yeah they're
just like i'm not message because that's
the message and that's what they see and
it's the the thing that the thing that
happened is that because it's there and
it's in their face it's really hard to
uh make sense of it
of course and make a logic of it because
there's there isn't there isn't and kids
understand that they can see that
they're
stupid yeah and they're gonna they're
gonna call it like it is and sometimes
the way they see it is like super brutal
and super you're going to put your kids
underneath a knife like you're perfect
the way you are okay what about you
that's rough this is why i just i would
support them with whatever they wanted
but at the same time
i have to ask them why they would want
to get that in the first place like
did i not give you enough validation as
well maybe your faith didn't give the
validation but go ahead if you did it
it's not about you it's about society
and the message that we send you can say
hey you're beautiful you're beautiful
no matter how many people told you you
were beautiful when you were younger it
didn't matter because the society still
viewed it differently you saw how people
got treated once they got boob implants
or they were more feminine or more
attractive or whatever it might be so
kids
and their young years the most important
part of their life is you know being at
home with their parents but once they
get around the age of like nine and ten
like the most developmental part in
terms of importance is schooling it's
the people around the community that's
why kids become distant around that age
from their parents so
it's not about you as an individual and
if they're at that place it's because
society's telling them you're not good
enough
plastic surgery is a solution
right
it's not like yo you're going to grow
older you're going to you're going to
develop a character you're going to be
able to manage your insecurities it's
not that get enough money and cut
yourself up right because me that's how
i was growing up it's like yo listen
[ __ ] i know it's hard
i know life is hard yeah you know what
got me through
work hard
but that's the only thing that you got
but that's my whole point yeah right
through labor
and through experience
you become
you develop other parts of yourself
which you rely on to support you you
understand yeah right like like there is
no workaround around that like for me
there wasn't any yeah right
what these people are being taught is
cut yourself up and you get to that
place right they just
they don't even make the whole rule
around the monopoly table they just get
quartered there's no pass go no give me
200 off the top straight up as a trans
person who goes through this sis hat
society
um people are always nitpicking at my
body they're always like you don't have
big enough boobs you don't have an ass
your face looks [ __ ] up you don't look
feminine you look masculine i kind of
wish that i never got breast
augmentation
not because like it makes me feel any
type of way but more so i wish i didn't
feel like i had to have boobs to feel
pretty
i didn't like my mother pushed that a
lot like you need to look feminine to be
beautiful and i'm like
again it comes back to the societal
underlying pressures it's rough yep well
you're perfect the way you are and the
way you carry it out okay so oh
see see this is where they lose me i'm
fine with the struggle i accept that
stop saying you're perfect the way that
you are you're not after [ __ ]
getting surgery okay because everybody
who now gets here is like oh so she's
perfect yeah but you're also perfect
without it so then if you're perfect
then why are you getting the surgery you
were perfect before and you're perfect
now what does that even mean where's the
progress what did you get surgery for
these are just lies okay these are our
innocent lives that we try to tell each
other to make each other feel good but
they're not true and women know it's not
true because they still want to get the
surgery even though everyone's like
you're a bad [ __ ] you a bad [ __ ] and
you perfect the ice queen but after you
yeah in front of the mirror you go home
and cry which is which is fun which
which is fine but yeah it is
it's a lot thing that happened is that
there's a lot of trans
i'm not not trans trans trans okay
what's up with you and lgbt
you just pulled out the rainbow for no
reason no it's not true
t-r-e-n-d-s thank you
yes
the trans people were like yo [ __ ] stop
talking about it
stop leaving's alone talking about you
but there's different
can you leave these [ __ ] alone
[Music]
it's just there's a certain way that
peop that
certain looks are in style for plastic
surgery yeah who knows certain looks are
in style and you can see it it's just
like tattoos you know what i mean
according to your tattoos you tell me
what tattoo you got i know when you got
it if you got a dragon i know it wasn't
around the year 2000 because it was the
euro dragon
if you had like a chinese symbol i know
it was like from 1995
uh to uh
99 2000 2001. if you had if you had a
[ __ ] um paw prints on your titties uh
you were in sync with this the first
album of eve uh i got one for you who's
that girl
titty paws go ahead
paw patrol late 90's early 2000's
women many women got this tattoo oh well
there was either tribal or uh
[ __ ] stamp lower back
um
you have your original barbed wire
that's before 98
uh there's a bunch there's a bunch
there's a bunch there's a bunch so those
trends yes you were saying so they're
the same thing that happened with
surgery with surgery there's strands now
right now you could look you could see
you could notice someone that is that
has injection in their lips because you
see the skin people
everybody has this all right we all have
that little uh you have your lip and you
have that that the edge of your lip
right and now what they're gonna do is
that they're gonna put that but that so
that
it goes the edge of the lips is over
it's bigger you can see it yeah it
couldn't pull it pulls forward but
that's a look
like people are usually not born with
perfect buoys or perfect anything so it
definitely does and it's not just
plastic surgery it's the fillers it's
the botox yeah exactly all that
snowballs into i mean so i sometimes get
complimented by people on the internet
being like oh you're such a natural
beauty and i'm like
baby oh [ __ ] i really wanted to hear the
girl in the black shirt talk about no i
don't contribute to that you didn't like
your boobs because they were odd shape
you know what you know what's natural
odd-shaped boobs
it is and you walk through the strongly
disagree no you contribute to that
because now your boobs look normal the
same way guess what they were normal
before oddly shaped boobs is normal
they're not never even they're never
they're never even it's just like balls
same thing they're never [ __ ] evil
they're never [ __ ] on the other side
and never like
you contribute to that you better walk
your ass on the other side boo-boo
boobs boobs
absolutely 100
i was beautiful i've always been i still
am and i will be my whole life this was
just a little a little salt a little
salt and pepper on top that's it a
little more flavor that's not how you
feel that's why you walked in there to
have the surgery you know breast
augmentation is a dangerous business
it's not that they just blop up boxes yo
your body can react it can cause you
cancer it's a real thing it's a real
[ __ ] thing so no you didn't feel like
that before the surgery that's not true
well my nose changed my whole life my
whole perception of my face so i i think
i'm beautiful now but before when i look
at pictures i'm like god damn i'm so
glad i got that nice job
i kind of agree with what you're saying
but at the same time i've always felt
like i'm beautiful from the inside out
no matter what anyone else tells me like
you're gonna tell me this whole [ __ ]
charade and the violent [ __ ] that you
just did right there you're gonna do all
that and after that i'm no i'm jeanette
no
that's not what you said this is the
this is no there's a lot of the fake
positivity
that a lot of people have listen that
i'm just not a big fan of and i get it
maybe it's a way to cope or maybe it's
way to send out positive messaging but
if everybody can know your messaging is
a lie it just seems i don't know i'm
just not a big fan look guys it's okay
to say i hated the way my face looked i
didn't think i was attractive back then
and now i really feel like all right i'm
good myself you know what i'm saying
like but i just don't buy it when
everyone says i was always beautiful and
i'm just more beautiful it's like okay
you put your life at risk to look a
little bit more beautiful really
okay
i don't know i just don't understand
that it's like it's not like these
people just went to the store and just
bought something they got cut up
underneath a knife 270 surgeries
270 surgeries and you thought you was
beautiful
you put your life at risk that many
times and you thought it was beautiful
before
come on bro that's a lot and that that's
the thing is people always keep on
saying that [ __ ] oh my you know some
firefight oh my god oh my god you're so
you know we need to normalize you know
what huh we need to normalize being
average you that's what i was about to
say it's okay you're not listen and
people out there
none of you [ __ ] are perfect
that's including me oh god please that
is absolutely including me you are not
perfect again none of you girls are
perfect none of you bros are perfect and
you know what
it's okay yes i just want kevin to come
in right now and say you're average at
best man don't interrupt me your average
had bet he could say that to me i'm like
yeah i'm pretty average [ __ ] yeah it's
okay it's okay we're not all beautiful
just stop it we're not all beautiful
some of us are ugliest yes some of you
guys are watching right now you guys are
ugly which is fine it's okay
ugly people find love with other ugly
people every day we just have to
normalize that [ __ ] people always
talking about oh you're perfect no the
[ __ ] i know you
you're not yes
and vast majority of people say you
aren't it's okay it's a lie you're not
perfect but i understand that like
coming to terms with that as a man's a
lot easier than it is for women but
i mean
reality is still reality and you're ugly
plastic surgery is a privilege so as a
trans person myself i feel like plastic
surgery is definitely a privilege
because even just being on hormones for
a trans person is a privilege and not
all of them are able to
access large amounts of money just to
get a procedure because you know they're
just not granted that it's not a
privilege anybody could have it to me oh
my god
the delusion hold up hold up let me hear
why why does she say it's not a
privilege it's not a privilege anybody
could have it really to me it sounds
like only certain groups certain you
know a socioeconomic group can get it
but anybody can get it
uh you know what no i'm not gonna
dignify that with a response that's
absolutely nonsensical some people
overdo it with plastic surgery
three
two
one
go if they say no
i want to hear the reasons oh jesus
from everybody
i think if you go to the point in which
it affects your health
nah that is too much so that would be
over doing it
i'm pretty sure that every surgery helps
post
potentially
but that's my whole point where to fix
your health you don't know that until
you go underneath the knife
you get what i'm saying yeah like oh you
got breast cancer you didn't know that
when you were getting underneath the
knife yeah when you get a bbl it's not
the safest procedures there's people who
die from that every year and a lot of
people it is considered the most
dangerous elective surgery you can get
even if you don't get cut up and you get
like just injection it can be very
harmful to your body but whatever your
reaction can be [ __ ] up but yeah you
don't know that i i can't look at them
saying like you know what oh they're
like that i'm like that i have plastic
surgery too it's not surgery but i have
braces and the same ammo
the ammo is the same i'm not saying that
everybody that has bra that have braces
is for the looks because some people
have surgeries that are you know
something is [ __ ] up either the jaw is
not working properly or creates other
problems stuff like that mine was not
the case my [ __ ] was just too distant in
the front and that's pretty much that's
pretty much [ __ ] the two front teeth
were distant relatives you understand
what i'm saying that's it but it was
really that it was not even my decision
my just my parents decided liz said
you're getting braces and that's okay
that's all right but of course if my
kids come up to me and be like uh my
[ __ ] crooked i i don't feel good about
myself i'm not going to be like i don't
know you're practicing the way you are
no your teeth is [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
uh which i'm gonna do about that it's a
conversation that we have to have you
know what i mean i'm not saying that i
would say that to my kids that are
perfect because they're not they came
for me and i'm not perfect okay and
that's pretty much and that's pretty
much the thing is it's really that's
what i got from this is
over people saying oh no you're perfect
you're perfectly perfect even i fell
into that oh no you're perfect
[ __ ] no
yo [ __ ]
wonky but you're right
why that's the thing we have to
normalize being normal being average
that was just fine
yeah
it's interesting right
where do you draw the line what is and i
think there's no clear definition for me
personally
i think if the surgery poses a threat
health threat i think it might be time
to reconsider
well what percentage that's a good
question
one percent two percent 0.5 i don't know
but when i'm hearing people dying during
these surgeries and you want to still do
it casually
i don't know to me it just seems a
little bit off and at the same time i'm
just generally not a big fan of folks
having to alter themselves physically
through like finances in order to
feel good about themselves but preach
raise a really good point you know maybe
it's also the fact that
like here's an example i'm fine with
braces i think veneers are stupid hmm
you know what i'm saying it's taking
what you already got and straightening
it out i could live with that
right it's just straightening it out
getting the whole [ __ ] taken off and
then putting in plastic teeth well
there's some people that put it over
okay sure but you get what i'm saying
yeah you know what i'm saying like i'll
look at some guy there's a comedian
there's a comedian gerard carmichael
okay
i know i watched him for some time and
then one day he got his face look
different what the [ __ ] wrong with his
face
his teeth and i'm like damn it just i
don't know
or the mayor here
and his veneers
what mayor it's not the guy who was
trying to run oh there yeah it's like
there's just something about it where
you start looking like a ken doll in
your mouth you know what i'm saying like
veneers are almost too perfect and you
look stupid yeah you know what i'm
saying like
maybe maybe i'm just weird like that i i
appreciate folks's weirdness and
imperfections like you know some folks i
know who were in their like 40s and they
got their gap tooth you got a little
that big old gap yeah michael strahan i
appreciate that [ __ ]
[ __ ] went that way
yes you went out there with them two
[ __ ] sticking out i don't know
shout out to you my dude uh and yeah you
did like yeah i'm just gonna
yeah you got a big ass forehead show it
some love [ __ ] getting hair
transplants to hide this [ __ ] it's okay
like you know what i'm saying but maybe
maybe that's just how i operate
yeah i like people who got like weird
stuff about them anyways all this to say
no you're not perfect the way you are
some of y'all [ __ ] ugly but
your imperfections can be dope and it's
okay yeah it's okay yeah all right let
us know what you guys think in the
comments